i always i say it this way i got to be
careful i can't let the kid at me kill
the king of me you know what i mean we
all got a kid in a king in us
and the king is our best us
but that kid is our crazy awesome yeah
he always wants to do crazy [ __ ] you got
to let him out sometimes you just got to
keep it to you and yourself and then
keep it quiet whatever you do keep it
quiet let them out and then get back to
your king so where did you transition
yeah was there like a moment where
you're like i can't keep doing this when
i first retired dawg and well i told you
i i had a system right yeah like and i
would be [ __ ] around getting high and
all season for that month and a half but
when i started you could lock it in it
was over yeah i never had a problem yeah
until i retired
and then i retired right and i said okay
okay okay okay uh uh
this will be last weekend let's have a
great one
have a great week
[Laughter]
go somewhere i don't know go get some
milk from the store and run into two or
three of them and then i was like
you know yeah and then i i went out
again i did yeah
and i was like whoa wait a minute man
wait a minute why am i doing things
after i said it was over it always
worked before when i said it was over
but this time i kept falling back and
falling back and then that's when i
realized because i had to start studying
my own self that all i was doing was
switching addictions yes so since i
didn't have anything
to put my energy in i couldn't come out
of what i was in yeah and that was it
and that that that was a tough thing
yeah that was a tough thing
i had to learn to stop doing all this
[ __ ]
you know obviously i i used to talk
about people how can they not stop why
are they strong enough to stop you know
yeah because you always had football
because i always had football right
and when i didn't have football oh
oh this is the kind of problem
got the time you got some money and you
just kind of fell back into it man so
once i learned that then i understood
what i needed to do and what did you
shift the addiction to
work you were like i got to go in right
right and that's why it's why i work the
way i work
it's an addiction yeah work is addiction
yeah
so maybe maybe life is addiction you
just got to find the way
let me put it this way maybe
success is addiction you just have to
make sure you put that focus and passion
into positive things instead of
drugs yeah yeah exactly exactly because
i relate to that right right but but now
when you say um success
happiness is the word i would put in
must be your addiction
winning football
championships made you more happy yeah
yeah what makes me happy man i
winning football was great and i love
football and i love nothing but but when
i see when i look at my little
granddaughters right now and i say to
them
papa go take care of you from the grave
that yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah papa will
be taking care of you yeah that probably
gonna be dead and gone yeah you're still
going so how did you how did you not
fall into the trap of like so many
athletes that spend all their money
living the extravagant lifestyle you you
can live the lifestyle that's not the
issue it's it's it's it's
it's how you get to live the lifestyle
that's the issue money is
you got to know how to spend your money
simple things simple things
and i i talk to young man about this all
the time because you gotta imagine okay
here's a young man he growing up like i
grew up with nothing nothing yeah with
nothing yeah and then it's not just he
grew up with nothing
what did he see he saw everybody that
had anything around him
get it taken repossessed
houses cars because they couldn't keep
up with payments this all he's right so
now he's just getting i'll do simple
numbers he just got a 5 million dollar
signing bonus
5 million dollar signing bonus and this
dude wants to say man yo
i got five million dollars here is
where what he could use what he used to
get to where he is so i called sometimes
your greatest asset greatest liability
right he used the the the poorness
around him the poor in in in the poverty
around him as few to make him a great
athlete to make it but now now he you
use your yesterday to set your tomorrow
but now your yesterday is hurting your
tomorrow because when he gets the five
million dollar signing bonus he says i
want to get my house i want to get my
cars so he spends
he buys a 2 3 million dollar house say
he spends a half a million dollars on
cars he's three and a half million
dollars yeah and he said i'm buying mine
flat out so nobody gonna come to i take
it from me like i saw them taking it
from everybody else around me stupidest
thing in the world yeah yeah yeah you
get a five million dollar you said it
over there you go ask somebody let me
borrow 300 three and a half million
dollars against about five million
dollars and i'm gonna buy all that stuff
i want but i'm gonna leave that five
million dollars sitting on principal and
then i'm gonna make the interest off
that five million dollars to pay back
the loan or the three and a half million
and i never touched my principal so you
cannot let the pain yesterday mess with
your tomorrow another thing we do and i
learned this from o.j simpson it's
called a family payback white women
it's called a family skipping dynasty
trust you put all of your family members
in on the name in this trust and that's
what i got irving family skipping
dynasty trust
anytime i give money out to anybody in
my family they get to pay the tax on the
money at their bracket so when i when we
pass our money as athletes yeah we give
to our families all the time we're
paying an hour we're giving it to them
at our tax rate
[Music]
when i give it to him
my mom taxed her
way different than mine yeah so so i'm
gonna end up giving her the money to pay
for the tax too but i'd rather you know
what i'm saying yeah
how do you pick these up like well my my
degree is in business first of all my
degree is the best business management
organization and back then you had to
graduate early to leave and go to school
early so i graduated after my junior
year of eligibility and went to the
draft that's how i controlled my draft
like like when green bay called with the
seven pick green bay like michael uh
we're going to draft a receiver right
here and we're thinking about no way
green bay
really
don't do it buddy don't do it i'm not
leaving florida for green bay wow really
it's not i'm too dark that's cause i
like the sun
don't do it don't do it and see they
couldn't drive me because if team drives
you i could have dropped the class going
back to summerslam
and they would have lost the drive
choice and i could apply for a
supplemental draft so i had total
control that's why i did i learned that
from bernie kozar when he graduated a
couple years the slowest quarterback
madden
the brokest dude in the world shouldn't
negotiate with the nfl
i was only going to play in dallas
la or new york
you